Remember that manager that we were talking about earlier? Maybe it was you,
maybe it was somebody else. Well, that manager is still handing out assignments
manually. Let's write the program that will assign them automatically. I've got
it started for you. I wrote a class simulation. You don't need to look at it
too hard. There's a lot of stuff in here that you don't need to know yet.
Mostly what it's doing is it's reading in a story. The story is a text file,
inside the directory with the code. It's called story.txt. The simulation class
reads these lines of the story on a manager object. Let's look again at this
story. First, the manager hires photographers. There's a photographer Danny,
then a photographer Leslie. Each day, there's a meeting, where the manager
gives out assignments. The manager's going to start with the first photographer
and give out the highest priority assignment available first. So in this case,
that would be the parrot assignment, which has priority 5. In between daily
meetings, the manager gets assignments. These assignments need to be added to
the to-do list. Since choosing a priority is a complicated task, I just
included the priorities for you. The priorities will be Ints, and a higher
number means a higher priority assignment, so the assignment should be done
sooner. When we come to the end of the story, we'll check the portfolio and
display all of the pictures. Your task will be to complete the methods inside
the manager class, using whatever other classes you need to create. So that
when you run the main method in the stimulation class, it will print out the
finished photos from left to right with no space between them and the name of
photographer under each picture. So when you run the main method of the
finished code, you should see something like this. The first photo is of a
parrot and it was done by Danny, the second one is of the mountain done by
Leslie and so on. Make sure that their signature has its top left corner, right
at the bottom left corner of the photo. Now I've written one other thing for
you, the photographer has the complicated job of creating a photo based on a
description. If this were real life, a person would be taking the photo and
loading it into the system, but we don't have time to wait for that. So I've
included some photos, and a method in the photographer class, that gives the
name of a file with a photo, when you give it a description. All of the
descriptions in the story, so all of these ones already have photos for them.
And the photographer knows how to find those photos. Aside from that, you have
free reign. You can add whatever classes you need to make this work. Though to
submit your answer, you'll need to find a way to use the classes that are in
the Udacity IDE. You can't make new files in the Udacity IDE. But if you use
BlueJ, you can create whatever classes you want. I'll give you a little tour of
how I designed my solution at the end. But there are a lot of ways to do this,
and many of them are good for different reasons. One last thing. I understand
that this is very open ended. So if you'd like more guidance, check out the
hint links that will show up here. And if you can't make it work, it's not your
fault. And if you're satisfied with your progress and what you've learned from
the question it's okay to move on.